今天想聊一個很有意思的案例，一家叫做 Ominimo 的新創公司，他們在短短兩年內就成為了獨角獸，更重要的是，他們居然是獲利的。
獲利？兩年就獨角獸？等等，這有點出乎意料啊。現在大部分科技新創不是都先燒錢擴張，然後才想著獲利嗎？尤其是保險科技這種需要大量資金投入的領域。
對啊，這就是我覺得特別「哇」的地方。你可能沒想到，他們從 2024 年成立，才兩年時間，估值就達到 14 億歐元，而且這次 B 輪募到的錢，不是拿來燒日常營運，而是加速成長。
這確實很特別。那他們具體是怎麼做到的？就保險業來說，競爭很激烈，要短期獲利，是不是有什麼秘密武器？
他們主要專注在車險產品，而且原文有提到，他們是用「高度分層、數據驅動定價」以及「專有保險科技」來做。這表示他們在定價上很精準，並且運用科技優化了營運。
「高度分層、數據驅動」聽起來很厲害，但實際操作上，要多精準才能做到獲利？會不會只賺到一些風險很低的客戶，而把高風險的都推掉了？
其實原文有提到，他們結合了保險專業知識、數據科學和軟體開發，目的是提高定價準確性、自動化保險營運，並提供更簡化的客戶體驗。這說明他們的核心是在「效率」上。
所以意思就是，他們透過精準定價和自動化流程，大幅降低了營運成本，才能在短期內就達成獲利？這個邏輯聽起來是成立的。
而且他們還有一組很強的團隊。原文說，他們現在大約 130 名員工，其中有八位數學奧林匹亞獎牌得主和一位物理奧林匹亞獎牌得主。團隊將近三分之二的人都在數據科學或軟體開發部門。
哇，這麼多奧數選手，難怪數據分析會這麼精準。這就解釋了他們為什麼能做到「高度分層、數據驅動定價」了。這對一般創業者來說，找人才的門檻有點高。
沒錯，但我想從中學習的不是去挖奧數人才，而是他們對「專業」的投入。他們從一開始就清楚自己的核心競爭力在哪裡，並且把大部分資源都投入在關鍵的技術和數據上。
嗯，這點我信了，畢竟原文數字也很清楚：2024 年他們的年化總保費營收是 2630 萬歐元，到了 2025 年就暴增到 1 億 5780 萬歐元，現在更是高達 3 億 680 萬歐元。這種成長速度在獲利的前提下，確實很驚人。
所以我覺得，如果我是個創業者或主管，從這個案例學到的就是，不要急著擴張市場或產品線，而是先想清楚「如何設計一個能穩定獲利」的商業模式。再把資金和人才聚焦在讓這個模式更有效率的核心環節。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念怎麼帶入工作或生活？難道也要變成數學天才嗎？
其實不一定。我覺得可以思考一下，我們自己的工作或生活裡，有沒有哪些環節是「燒錢」又「沒效率」的？是不是可以學 Ominimo，用更精準的策略、更有效率的方法，來達成目標，而不是一味投入資源？
比如說，如果我負責一個專案，與其每個環節都投入相同的人力物力，是不是可以先分析哪個環節最影響成本或效率，然後集中資源去優化它？
對，就是這個意思。它好像也提醒了我們，有時候，少即是多，聚焦在最關鍵的點上，反而能帶來更健康的成長。